I feel sometimes the media the
commenteriat and you know a lot of
people you know around our business
slightly fall into a trap of Gleason see
that it is just written in the stars
that the labor party is going to win the
next general election that these you
know substantial poll numbers will just
stick until the next general election so
the question now becomes always
kyostarma becoming too Centrist is he
becoming you know too boring because
he's too focused on winning an election
which is in the bag no nothing is in the
bag yeah I was speaking to a senior
labor person the other day their worry
is that these pool leads are in fact
soft as butter you have an example like
the Diane Abba um issue it raises the
whole thing of anti-Semitism again it's
like it's a massive kind of open goal
for the labor party and you just look at
history there is nothing
um that that suggests that labor is you
know predetermined to win any election